Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Ben & Jerry's
in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In the UK, Ben & Jerry's comes with
a standard tub size of 465 milliliters.
And the cores tubs are the same size.
Look at this little cute guy.
In the US, we start with these mini tubs.
They're 118 milliliters, or 4 ounces.
A standard US Ben & Jerry's pint
is 16 ounces, or 473 milliliters.
And also like in the UK,
our cores, this guy right here,
is the same size as our regular pint.
Our topped tubs are
actually slightly smaller.
They are 15.2 fluid
ounces, or 450 milliliters.
One thing to note is that despite
the two being very similar sizes,
the UK does not refer
to its tubs as pints.
That's because pints
are actually different
in the UK and the US.
Here in the US, we measure our liquids
using US customary measurements,
which is based on an
18th-century English –
who cares, all right?
Our pint is 16 fluid ounces.
In the UK, we use imperial measurements,
which were only established in 1824,
after the US had declared independence.
Our pints are 568 milliliters,
which is 1.2 times larger than a US pint.
To illustrate the difference,
I've brought in an
imperial-measurements measuring jug.
We're going to fill it with ice cream.
That just looks like the best milkshake
you've ever had, honestly.
According to Target,
this is 16 fluid ounces.
So we're gonna put this in
here and see what happens.
And in case you still don't believe us,
this is a British pint glass.
We're gonna fill this with ice cream.
Joe: Here we go.
While I've got this pint in front of me,
it would be kind of rude not to try,
wouldn't it? Cheers.
[sighs] All right.
[Harry laughs]
Joe: Found the walnuts.
It was going really
well, then I hit a lump.
I'm down to about here though.
Pretty strong, I think.
[Joe burps]
It's the lumps that get you. But honestly,
not the worst way to eat Ben & Jerry's.
I mean, as much as I can get,
then I gotta start eating
it. How does that look?
Fun fact: This is
actually how Ryan Gosling
ended up gaining 60
pounds for a movie role,
which he then got fired from.
So, ended up being a little
bit of a waste of time,
but pretty effective way to pile on mass.
Now, while the volume of ice cream you get
in the two countries is
theoretically pretty similar,
one other thing we wanted to check
was how much topping you
get mixed in with your tub.
Here's a pint of Cookie Dough in the US.
We've let it melt. So
we're going to strain it
to see how many cookie-dough
chunks are in a pint.
We'll do the same over here. Let's go.
Oh, yeah, that ice cream is totally
catching up with me right now.
I swear to God, if I throw up ...
The style of this reminds me of the net
you use to catch bugs in Animal Crossing,
with the little ...
whichew!
Joe: Here we go.
Yeah, this is completely
arbitrary. Here we go.
Doesn't look very appetizing
when you put it like that, does it?
I have to sift through this, I guess.
Yeah, these are all -- one, two ...
Just another day at the
office, really, isn't it?
12, 13, 14, 15?
So, in a UK tub of Cookie Dough,
we got around 33 pieces
of actual cookie dough
in varying sizes.
While we're going into excruciating detail
on the portion sizes, why not take a look
at the cores tubs as well?
[ice cream thuds]
It's the same flavor in the US.
Let's cut this bad boy open.
Ha-ha!
I can still eat this after
I've sawed it in half?
Is there anything, any chemicals on here
that are likely to kill me?
We'll find out.
[ice cream thuds]
Ooh!
[heavenly music]
That core doesn't go all the way in there.
It's kind of like ...
Chocolate, vanilla, salted caramel core.
Just pick it up.
I mean, I didn't wash the saw.
A bit of woody oak flavor.
Here are all the Ben & Jerry's
items you'll find in the UK
that you won't find in the US.
And here are most, actually half,
of the US-exclusive Ben & Jerry's flavors.
We'll start with this one,
which is the Birthday Cake ice cream.
I haven't actually tried this before,
but apparently it's vanilla
cake batter ice cream
with pink frosting, strawberry
swirls, and cake pieces.
Americone Dream.
This is the Stephen
Colbert-flavored ice cream.
I'm not quite sure what Steve tastes like,
but it looks like they got
his essence in this pint.
Speaking of ice cream
that is person-flavored,
The Tonight Dough. Look,
you see that right there?
There is absolutely no way
that's his hand holding that cone.
Good job on the Photoshop, those guys.
The Berry Sweet Mascarpone.
Another one you can
only get here in the US.
Would be something – I'll
be straight up with you,
as an Italian man, I'm
about to say something
very controversial, but
this flavor, when I saw it,
I was like, "Yuck! No, thank you."
Where is it? It is literally
the first one in front of me.
Ben & Jerry's Cannoli flavor.
A "Mascarpone Ice Cream with Fudge-Covered
Pastry Shell Pieces &
Mascarpone Squirrels."
Squirrels. "Swirls."
Next up, we've got this one,
which is Cookie Dough S'Wich Up.
Next up we've got the Dough-ble Chocolate
Cookie Dough Twist.
Caramel Chocolate Cheesecake.
This is a no-brainer right here.
I bet this one's pretty good.
"What's in it?" You ask.
"Caramel Cheesecake Ice
Cream with Cheesecake Pieces,
Chocolate Cookie Swirls." Hell yeah, dude.
This is going in the Joe pile.
Cherry Garcia. They don't
have Cherry Garcia in the UK?
Doesn't that seem weird?
This is, like, when everyone
found out about Ben & Jerry's,
I feel like. Cherry Garcia was –
I have no idea if this was before
Jerry Garcia died or in tribute of him.
Chocolate Peanut Butter Split.
I'm gonna assume it's
chocolate and peanut butter.
What do you guys think?
Chocolate Therapy.
"Chocolate Ice Cream
with Chocolate Cookies
& Swirls of Chocolate Pudding."
Like, every consistency of chocolate.
Ah, the Chubby Hubby.
Thought this one was, like, super popular.
Chunky Monkey was earlier, it
was banana and walnuts and ...
it's the one I drank.
It's not sitting right. Ugh.
Next up we've got Cone Together,
which I'm guessing is
a "Come Together" pun.
Did The Beatles do "Come Together"?
I really, I'm not a Beatles guy.
I just listen to Owl City,
so I'm not the person
to come to for classic music advice.
Cinnamon Bun.
Tastes like cinnamon buns.
Coffee Coffee BuzzBuzzBuzz.
Maybe this instead of your
morning coffee. [laughs]
Coffee Toffee Bar Crunch.
Everything But The dot dot dot.
It has a lot of stuff in here.
Gimme S'more.
Glampfire Trail Mix.
Go-To Cold Brew, another coffee one.
Next up we've got Baked Alaska.
Now, I've actually never
eaten a proper baked Alaska,
but I presume it tastes similar to this.
This has got vanilla ice cream
with marshmallow swirls
and white polar bears.
Then we go into the Caramel
Chew Chew ice cream.
New York, baby! Super Fudge Chunk.
Salted Caramel Almond.
Not as many punny ones
as I thought, right?
Vanilla Caramel Fudge.
I wonder what's in it.
Milk and Cookies.
Peanut Butter Half Baked.
So it's a combination of
the two most popular ones.
That's pretty smart, actually.
What? This is crazy! This can't be right.
Vanilla?
Why don't you have vanilla in the UK?
Then our lost classic tub
is Sofa So Good Together.
I'm not sure why they
needed the "Together."
I feel like the pun works
better without the "Together."
Ben & Jerry, if you're
listening, fix this.
The Punch Line.
Chillin' the Roast truffles.
Pistachio Pistachio.
Oat of this Swirled.
OK, now we're getting back on the puns.
Strawberry Cheesecake.
And this isn't even all of them.
In the US, you can also
get flavors such as
Boots on the Moooo'n,
Brewed to Matter,
Chocolate Shake It,
Cold Brew Caramel Latte,
Ice Cream Sammie,
Justice ReMix'd,
Mint Chocolate Cookie,
Peanut Butter World,
Red, White & Blueberry,
Triple Caramel Chunk,
Urban Bourbon,
Pumpkin Cheesecake,
Totally Unbaked.
That's just the regular ones.
We got a lot more to go through.
We also have a few
nondairy and low-calorie
exclusives in the UK.
We'll start at the end with this one,
which is Save Our Swirled NOW.
Then we have one more nondairy exclusive,
which is this one:
Cookies on Cookie Dough.
Here in the US, you can
get the, in nondairy form,
Americone Dream and The Tonight Dough,
"Milk" and Cookies,
Cherry Garcia,
Chocolate Caramel Cluster
and Mint Chocolate Cookie,
Caramel Almond Brittle,
Crème Brûlée Cookie,
ooh, the Netflix & Chilll'd,
Peanut Butter Half Baked,
and Phish Food.
A few other flavors you can get in the US
that you can't get in the UK, nondairy,
that I also couldn't get
in the US but I've assumed
are available somewhere in this country
are the Karamel Sutra Core, nondairy,
the Coconut Seven Layer Bar, nondairy,
and the Coffee Caramel Fudge, nondairy.
Then we're on to some low-calorie options,
which Ben & Jerry's calls Moo-phoria.
Now, this one up here is
a Chocolate Cookie Dough,
low-calorie version,
but it's only 136 calories
per 100 milliliters.
Our next Moo-phoria exclusive flavor
is the Salted Caramel Brownie one.
The next Moo-phoria
exclusive we were able to get
was this one: Poppin Popcorn.
The Moo-phoria light flavors
you can get in the US are:
Chocolate Cookie Enlightenment.
[drumroll]
EnlightenMint, M I N T.
Very good, Ben & Jerry's.
Chocolate Milk and Cookies,
Mocha Fudge Brownie,
P.B. Marshmallow.
I am slightly against the concept
of low-calorie ice cream.
I feel like with something like this,
you just have to enjoy it as
it was intended to be enjoyed,
which is the proper way.
If you're going to save some calories,
maybe just save them elsewhere
and then treat yourself,
or just eat less of one of these
instead of a whole tub of that.
As you saw when I hacked
one open with a saw,
Ben & Jerry's also sells cores ice cream,
which is ice cream flavors with a core
of usually some kind of
caramel filling in the middle.
We've only got one exclusive
over here, which is this one,
the Blondie Brownie Core.
♪ We got the cores ♪
In the US, we got a bunch of cores
you can't get in the UK.
The Boom Chocolatta Cookie Core,
Chocolate Chip Cookie Dough Core,
Sweet Like Sugar Cookie Dough Core,
Wake and "No Bake" Cookie Dough Core,
Brownie Batter Core,
Cookies and Cream Cheesecake Core,
Peanut Butter Fudge Core,
and Salted Caramel Core.
We got all eight of them right here.
In the US, we can also get
these exclusive topped pints.
Now, from what I understand,
'cause I've never had one,
the ice cream has a layer of topping.
You used to be able get these in the UK,
but now you can't anymore.
Whiskey Biz,
the PB Over the Top,
and the Tiramisu.
But you can also get a Strawberry Topped
and a Thick Mint Topped.
Frozen yogurt.
US Ben & Jerry's also has
two frozen-yogurt options,
whereas the UK does not have any.
Sorry, guys, but we can
get frozen-yogurt versions
of Cherry Garcia and Half Baked.
[groaning] Ice cream!
All right, in the US,
we got these mini tubs.
You can get them in four flavors.
I could only find one.
You get them in Americone
Dream, Cherry Garcia,
nondairy Caramel Chocolate Chunk,
and nondairy PB & Cookies.
I've actually never had Cherry Garcia.
Into the palate.
Ooh, that's a 10 right there, baby.
Similarly to the topped tubs,
we also used to be able to
get mini tubs in the UK,
but unfortunately they
were recently discontinued.
Outside of tubs of ice cream,
Ben & Jerry's also has some
no-spoon-needed options in the UK.
This is an exclusive one right here,
which is a Cookie Dough Peace Pop.
We do not have the no-spoon options,
but we do have the pint slices,
and you can get them in the forms of:
Amaze-Mint,
Americone Dream,
Cherry Garcia,
Chocolate Chip Cookie Dough,
Chocolate Fudge Brownie,
and The Tonight Dough.
Final no-spoon-needed exclusive
we have here in the UK
is this one, which is Salted
Caramel Cookie Dough Chunks.
Cookie dough chunks, we got them too!
And these are some of the exclusive
cookie dough chunk bags from Ben & Jerry's
you can get in the US.
You got the Sugar Cookie Dough.
This one I mentioned earlier, Half Baked,
6 ounces for some reason.
All the other ones are 8.
I don't know why they did that.
The Chocolate Chip Cookie Dough
and Peanut Butter Chocolate
Chip Cookie Dough.
You can also get The Tonight Dough,
[Cinnamon Bun] Dough,
Gingerbread Cookie Dough,
and a vegan Chocolate Chip Cookie Dough.
One US-exclusive Ben Jerry's item that,
people, I assure you,
I tried, I tried, I tried
to get my hands on it
in time for the shooting.
Just couldn't happen.
Ben & Jerry also has two
dog flavor ice creams.
Now, they're not flavored like dogs,
they're flavors for dogs.
The Doggie Desserts is
what they're calling them.
And the two flavors are
Pontch's Mix and Rosie's Batch.
So, unfortunately, no
doggo wars in this episode,
but here are the pictures
of Paul and Luda.
Here's a picture of ice cream.
Can someone in graphics make it look
like they're eating the ice cream?
Quick clarification before we
start the nutrition section.
Ice cream is kind of tricky to quantify,
because sometimes it's
referred to by weight
and other times by volume.
It is because the containers
are all the same size, yes,
but the density of ice cream can vary.
So, overall, seems the fairest
way to measure is by weight.
In the UK, Ben & Jerry's provides its
nutritional information per 100 grams,
whereas in the US they
do it per serving size,
which is around 141 or 142 grams,
depending on which type
of ice cream you have.
So if we divide the US
serving by 1.41 or 1.42,
we should get a roughly
equivalent figure. Got it?
Let's start with what is officially
the most popular Ben & Jerry's
flavor in the United States.
That is this, the Half Baked.
100 grams of USA's Half
Baked contains 262 calories,
13.4 grams of fat, 7.8 of
which are saturated fat,
31.9 grams of carbs, 25.5
grams which are sugar,
and 90 milligrams of sodium.
100 grams of UK Half Baked
contains the following:
264 calories, 13 grams of fat,
8.1 grams of which is saturated,
32 grams of carbs,
of which 27 grams are sugar,
and 84 milligrams of sodium.
So it looks like the
UK's is actually higher
in saturated fat, carbs,
calories, and sugar,
although the US edges us
on total fat and sodium.
What is the most calorific
flavor in the US, you ask?
Turns out it is the Peanut Butter Cup.
I couldn't find it.
This magically delicious
peanut-butter-cup-flavored
Ben & Jerry's ice cream that
is somewhere in this country,
100 grams of it contains the following:
330 calories,
23.3 grams of fat,
12.6 of those are saturated fat,
25.3 grams of carbs,
22.5 grams which are sugar,
and 126 milligrams of sodium.
The same ice cream in the UK contains
310 calories, 21 grams of fat,
of which 12 grams are saturated,
24 grams of carbs,
of which 23 grams are sugar,
and 176 milligrams of sodium.
This time we edged the
UK on calories, fat,
saturated fat, and carbs,
while they beat us in sugar and sodium.
Now, these 100-gram
figures don't seem so bad,
but bear in mind that they
are for less than one serving.
Realistically, I'm eating
a whole tub of this
while cuddled up in my blankets,
depressed, watching Netflix.
If you were to eat a whole pint
of the Peanut Butter Cup ice cream, don't.
The stats do not look good for you.
Two figures to watch out for would be
the 270% of your daily
saturated fat allowance,
and almost 200% of your daily sugar.
Blech.
Here are the numbers for a full tub
of Peanut Butter Cup in the UK.
Keep in mind that our tub is
a tiny bit smaller than
the US one, but overall,
we are still better off than
them in most of the metrics.
Here is everything that's in a tub
of Ben & Jerry's Half Baked
in the UK.
Joe: In the US.
Harry: Cream, water,
Joe: Cream, liquid sugar,
Harry: sugar,
Joe: which is sugar and water,
Harry: condensed skim milk,
Joe: skim milk, water,
Harry: wheat flour,
Joe: sugar,
Harry: brown sugar,
Joe: wheat flour,
[fast-forwarding]
[fast-forwarding intensifies]
Seamless.
These are actually pretty
much identical lists,
so good job, Ben & Jerry.
There's also nothing in there
which you should be
particularly concerned about.
And this is kind of in
line with Ben & Jerry's
overall philosophy about
sourcing ingredients.
According to the Ben & Jerry's website,
they boast that their
ice cream is non-GMO,
fair trade, and cage-free.
And they do seem to live up to that.
All you "Food Wars" heads
watching this episode
know that we always have to deal with
artificial flavors that are OK in the US
but not allowed in the European Union.
But the ones that Ben & Jerry use
are actually made with natural colors,
like vegetable juice,
spirulina, and turmeric.
So while what's in the ice cream
might not be too interesting,
what's outside it is
actually worth pointing out.
In the US, the Ben & Jerry pints
do come in a cardboard tub
that has [polyethylene]
plastic on both sides.
In the UK, however, they've
actually stopped coating
the outside of the tubs,
which makes them more widely recyclable.
Ben & Jerry's have said
that it is their goal
to replicate this in the
US at some point this year,
which would save 79,000
pounds of plastic a year.
That's it?
Conner: Got it.
Joe: Got it.
[laughing] How much chocolate
do I have on my face?
[Joe singing]
♪ Ice cream ♪
That looks like my cat after
he's had an upset stomach.
You know, a little present
he'll leave on the carpet.